hello and welcome to the 13th PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be talking about multi-dimensional
arrays arrays with an arrays so with
that let's get into it we're gonna call
this we're gonna call this an e array
equals and this will be array specify
area right up in here
and we're gonna say we're just going to
make this well first of all to be
two-dimensional but you could go three
dimensional four dimensional I mean you
can go crazy with this but for now let's
just do let's say we're going to
categorize male and female so we're
gonna say a male and then we're gonna
have female but let's go ahead and
define male first all the way so a male
is going to be and then what you'll do
is instead of like before then you just
specify the value now the value of male
is another array and within the array
we're gonna have let's just put like
three names in here just populate it
will say Jeff Bob and Bill next up comma
because as always like like before you
just did the array you defined it comma
the next part of you right so now it's
going to be a female equals greater than
sign and then this one will be another
array within this array we'll have
through three chick names as well and
sorry women you guys don't want to be
called shapes
we'll call you three lady memes and
we're gonna have Kelly Stephanie
and Amy now will close this off and then
don't forget our semicolon and now we
have a multi-dimensional array so if you
think about it we've got categories male
and female and then underneath those
categories we've got names that
correspond to the category so to speak
so what we what we should do is find a
way to organize this like on page if
only there was a way oh yeah like I said
we were going to talk about the for each
loop so let's go ahead and mention Li
for each loop with that what we will do
is we're gonna call out each part of the
array and then list all the entities
within the array and while we're at it
why not make this a little bit easier to
read for the eyeballs right because this
is a really long line long line itis as
the people like to say not me though so
we'll do that right and then we'll do
female will stick female to right under
here with male cuz that looks good
females under male anyway this will be
good I think yeah no way that way like
whenever you're coding it's always
helpful to kind of structure things so
like well while you're running just like
a two-dimensional array and we only have
like two things and then three things in
there it's really not too hard to keep
up but like when mail if mail had like
50 names in it I'm gonna be really
tedious to finally find your way to
female and same thing if we had like I'm
trying to think something else we
categorize I don't know we had like you
know 15 categories and so as you can see
if they're imagined it would get pretty
difficult so you can kind of like break
it down like this
either way it's always going to function
so the next thing we want to do is head
up into the for each loop and
for that I'm actually gonna do another
video so hop on over to that video as
always thanks for watching